things seem to be heating up for kanye
west and uncut gem star julia fox as e.t
is learning more about the rapper's
dating life since splitting from kim
kardashian with a source telling us he's
dating around and trying to move on from
the reality star i'm just extremely
happy can you tell by my face
the rapper and actress were snapped in
new york city on tuesday night kanye
sporting a blue hoodie a black bomber
jacket black jeans and black rubber
boots with gloves to match
julia in a blue crushed velvet coat over
an all black look and according to
multiple reports the pair enjoyed dinner
and a show reportedly seeing the
broadway production of slave play
followed by a meal at italian hot spot
carbone just something for my heart of
course their nyc date night marks the
fourth outing for the duo who spent the
holiday weekend together in miami where
they had a double date with drink
champ's host noriega and his wife niri
and the 44 year old grammy winner held a
surprise new year's eve party with
fellow rapper future so who is julia
exactly well you might just remember the
31 year old actress from adam sandler's
2019 suspenseful drama uncut gems
hey
sorry to bother you
what is it
i just wanted to see how the auction
went terrible
i don't i don't want to talk about it
what was it like for you to work with
him because you know we all grew up
watching billy madison happy gilmore it
was really surreal i would say i was
more nervous like before i met him when
then when i met him he just became like
this person this nice
dad figure kind of you know he's just an
all-around really nice guy like a good
good person
e.t spoke to julia at the premiere of
the film which she attended with her
then husband how much are we wearing in
jewels tonight i would say probably like
400 000 something like that
you have security with you i have my
husband and he's pretty tough and
russian and scary so no one's coming
close to me
according to reports the actress
allegedly revealed on instagram last
month that she's now separated from her
husband the two married in 2018 and
share an 11-month old son
as for kanye a source tells e.t he's
been in good spirits lately and having
fun spending time with friends going out
and doing his thing quote he's been
trying to move on from kim and meet new
women he's dating around and figuring
out what he likes in a potential partner
of course this all comes after the
musician purchased a 4.5 million home on
the same street as his estranged wife
and their four children
the hidden hills california home
complete with five bedrooms and four
bathrooms was purchased on december 20
shortly after the skims founder filed to
expedite the termination of their
marriage a source previously explained
to e.t that kanye purchased the
residence to be close to kim and their
kids the pair shares eight-year-old
north six-year-old saint three-year-old
chicago and two-year-old psalm
kanye saw a house on kim's block was on
the market and jumped at the chance to
get it the source notes that the
musician thinks it will be easier to
co-parent with kim if they live close to
each other and kim she agrees quote kim
is fine with kanye buying the home
because she feels like it will be easier
to co-parent and watch their kids in
privacy
[Music]
you